Speaker 1: All right, my friends, let's take a
tour through the disaster porn. That is the George
Santos fiasco. As many of you know, George Santos
is the Republican congressman who has lied about
everything. He lied about his education. He lied
about his employment history. He lied about being
Jewish. He lied about being a volleyball star. He
lied about when and how and how seriously he got
COVID and was hospitalized and tested positive.
I don't know if any of those things are even true
at this point in time. And there are even more
lies. And, you know, I tweeted about some of
these people thought I was kidding. It's become a
meme to say Emmy Award winner George Santos. And
people go, yeah, okay, funny Emmy Award. He didn't
really say that he won an Emmy that I'm aware of.
And I tweeted. George Santos claimed that he had
two knee replacements from being a volleyball star
and people thought it was one of those jokes. It's
not. He really claimed this. There is there is now
a lie upon lie. George Santos falsely claimed
he was a volleyball star at Baruch College in
New York. He now has been caught on video claiming
that he was such a star that it led to him messing
up his knees and needing to knee replacements.
It doesn't appear to be true. This was on the
Sid and Friends in the Morning program back
in 2020. Listen to this. This is unbelievable.
Speaker 2: George Santos running against Tom
Suozzi in the third Congressional District coming
up next Tuesday. Hey, you know what's funny,
George? You go right to the heart here of me,
Sid and Bernie. At the very end of your
biography, it says in his spare time,
right. George Anthony enjoys volleyball and
tennis. Let me tell you why that's funny. You're
on this show. Bernie's daughter, Melanie.
Speaker 1: It's funny because we're all
liars as well.
Speaker 2: Was a
star volleyball player in college, and my
daughter Ava, as we speak, is working on
a tennis scholarship when she goes to college.
Speaker 1: So now it's not enough that they're
all volleyball stars, even though George Santos
was not. George Santos is such a star that now he
says he had two knee replacements. It's amazing.
Speaker 2: So the two sports that you seem to
enjoy on the weekends are the same two
sports. Our two daughters excelling.
Speaker 1: A daughter.
Speaker 3: So funny. I
actually went to school on on a volleyball
scholarship. I know what I did. Yeah. When I
was in Peru, we were the number one volleyball.
Speaker 2: Country from there. Did you graduate
from there? Yeah, so did I. I did. So did I.
Speaker 1: Oh, very. That's a lie.
Speaker 3: Oh, it's a great school. Great
institution. Very good. Very good. Very
good. Professors. You don't show their
bias, which is. Which is very interesting,
but that's a whole nother conversation. But
it's funny that we went to we went to to play
against Harvard, Yale, and we play them.
Speaker 1: I spiked four home runs and
three touchdowns, and then my knees exploded.
Speaker 3: We were champions across the entire
Northeast corridor. Every school that
came up against us, they were shaping
at the time. And funny, I was the smallest
guy and I'm six two. We had on our block.
Speaker 1: Is he six two? I mean, that's probably
a lie, right? I don't know. He just. He lies. We
should fact check his height on our on our ball.
Speaker 3: On our block alone were six, seven,
six, eight. These guys were jumping. They're
just stretching their arms up. Yeah, we were.
We weren't. And all of us could have been
playing basketball, but we chose volleyball
because of the easier that was. That was a great
time. I look, I sacrificed both my knees and got
very nice replacements for new replacements
from Asia. Yeah, playing volleyball. That's
how serious I took the game, you guys.
Speaker 1: I mean, he actually. Listen,
he had knee replacements. They were just on other
people's knees. He organized knee replacements for
other people. Give the guy a break. He actually
had four knee replacements on three knees,
if you would believe it. It's just one of the
young it's a record, actually, for how young and
the number of knee replacements he's had. Lying
and lying and lying. This is a sick person. This
is an illness. But that doesn't mean we excuse
it. Right. The fact that he seems to have this
inability to control his lying doesn't mean we
say so. He should get to stay in Congress. He
should resign. The pressure is building and it
appears that he has even lied about his name.
There is something you use at home every day that
is significantly harming the planet. And it is
your toilet paper. 30 million trees are destroyed
every year for toilet paper in the US alone.
Deforestation is a contributor to climate change
and I think moving away from tree based toilet
paper is something we can all do. And that's why I
asked real paper to be our sponsor. Real paper is
a toilet paper made 100% from bamboo stocks which
grow forever. So no cutting down trees and all of
real paper's packaging is plastic free. Think of
all those big plastic bags you've thrown out over
the years. Real paper is a B Corp certified by the
Forest Stewardship Council and real paper plants
one tree with every purchase you make. And the
best part is you can do a part to fight climate
change without making any sacrifice. Because
real paper is soft and fluffy and durable,
just like traditional toilet paper you're used
to. Guys, this is a no brainer for anyone who
cares about the issue of deforestation. Give real
paper a try. Go to real paper dot com slash pacman
and use the code pacman for 30% off your first
order plus free shipping. The link is down below.